what a masterpiece yeah beautiful the stars have aligned like it's amazing that's how it always
feels you know with these things is like wow look at this you know alignment phenomenal
all righty man how you doing yo yo yo sup dude how are you pretty good i'm i'm actually feeling
extra good right now ask me why okay why because your boy just found a new subdomain takeover
zero day right before this call and yeah i got i got my homies scanning for it they're popping left
and right i don't even do subdomain takeovers anymore but i just recently got back into the
game just because i saw this asset that looked like it was going to be possible so nice i'm pretty
hype it it it you know i talk about the recon game being a bit of a grind you know like doing really
wide recon always having to update your tools always having to uh you know increase the speed
and efficiency of your tools to compete with other people but man does it feel good when you just like
pop something and you just see like boom boom boom boom boom ah that's awesome so is this like a whole
new like uh like class or like a whole service or is like a like you know like shop yeah it's a new
service um it's not you know i say zero day and it is a zero day but it's it's not you know it's not
something mega technical it's just a new service that there's not any documentation on um you know
this service being able to be subdomain taken over subdomain takeovered turn that into a verb for you
um so i was pretty excited about it it it was really easy um but yeah i think people just don't
think about it from a new perspective anymore a lot of times people will just google hey can i do
subdomain takeover on bloody blah and then just stop there if there's no results but really you got
to go pay like we always say man you got to go pay the the entrance fee to get access to the control
panel to see if you can register the domain yourself and a lot of times you'll take an l and you won't
and you'll pay that you know 50 bucks or whatever it was to get access to that service but the other
times you know stuff will pop in it and it's great nice well that's awesome dude that that that's i
mean that's just you know showing that the stuff we talk about like it's here it is being used in
the real world it works man it works all right awesome let's see what we got um so news as far as
news goes once again we've got a pretty good lineup today um this episode's probably going to be a
little bit light joel and i both have some extra stuff going on this week but um we do have a decent
amount of news stuff so let's uh let's take a peek at that yeah cool so the first thing that came
up was from um uh an operator no operator my boy an operator yeah an operator so um i don't know you
know you may have heard but there was a new tld that was released the dot zip tld so they oh yeah
that caused a whole thing on twitter yeah so google if you don't know google owns a lot of
different tlds um i think honestly i think it's just like one of their hobbies they just collect
tlds so then you know did you know they own dot new as well so like really yeah so you can go to
docs.new or sheets.new or slides.new and it makes no way yeah yeah it makes like a new google doc
google sheets what you know file or whatever yeah so like what the heck joel why how do you go all this
it's crazy i don't even remember how i found that at one point but like yeah so you can do like docs.new
that's like one of my favorite ones that i use to like make new documents and stuff that's awesome
but they also own dot zip you know they own dot google anyways wow i feel like that's kind of a
sea surf though like i can just create a bunch of new documents by making a request to docs.new
yeah docs.new it's super interesting dude hold on wait did that like hold on hold on did that just
like stick it in my google drive yeah what but i think google docs you can have you can have like
anonymous well it won't autosave until you put something in it i think okay okay okay but i was
gonna say because if you could just like have someone come to your page window.open docs.new like
50 times instantly just blow up their google drive that would be real annoying it wouldn't necessarily be
old in real time yeah but like it would be annoying yeah yeah so it's super interesting um
but yeah they own dot zip as well like this the this dot tld um or this tld and they released it to
the public so you can register domains on the dot zip uh subdomain or okay i'm sorry you still got
me on the dot oh yeah yeah so so okay so yeah i'm sorry continue you're saying the dot zips they they
have dot zip now yeah i saw that yeah yeah so now you can you can register you know my domain dot zip
and the you know the observant listener can probably already see where this is going because dot zip is
for zip files it's a very commonly used file extension out in the wild um so you can see the
potential for tricking people into visiting a domain or having it at the end of a command or something
and so an operator put together this awesome like basically a proof of concept that shows
okay like imagine i send you this uh command this wget command uh you know it just downloads like a zip
from the github releases and then it unzips it and in the screenshot that they show it's downloading
like the zip it looks all completely normal you unzip it and it's got their pwned content in it
and it took me like a really long time to figure out how this worked same man i commented on that and i
was like hey man what the heck is going on and he he got me confused with like the way that his
like because he posted a command that has of ls right at the end and it got me all hecked up because
i i couldn't read it because the columns were switched around from normal ls because he's using
something weird but i to be honest man like i don't know i kind of thought everybody was overreacting
when this came out and and you know at the end to be fair it's not the biggest deal in the whole world
but um definitely you know when i clicked on operators post here um and you scroll down here
hold on i don't i think it's in the doc hold on yeah it's it's uh yeah it's the second no i'm gonna put
it in the doc for you real quick so you can see what i'm talking about um it's this so go to that
post and then scroll down to um the the stack overflow uh image in that post so if you go to
an operator's post there's a stack overflow image and i would absolutely just go to that w get double
click on it and then paste it into my terminal and press enter yeah i mean 100 like it's it's extremely
like it looks like very like you know like it doesn't look malicious at all it just looks like
any other like set of commands or whatever that you would copy and paste from like from like a
stack overflow post right yeah i really like the the breakdown that he did a little bit later too
where he actually breaks it out and says okay the first you know just by adding a space here
we're able to skip that whole github section and then just make source code.zip the thing that he
reaches out to yeah so yeah so yeah you basically yeah what you just talked about there is like kind
of like the little secret so in the screenshot it's not obvious at all like even in the original
like tweet that they made you yeah you don't really like understand just because of the way that the
line wraps around the terminal and stuff there's actually a space after the like the one url and
then followed by like he owns source code.zip source-code.zip right and so like you would expect
that this would download source code.zip but what you don't realize is there's a space and it's actually
two different urls and since source code.zip is a valid domain now it resolves it and then it it like
downloads it and so you could just see like it's literally like one space difference right like
you add a space and you and you're pwned so sneaky man yeah and then i bet i bet you could actually
also sort of um combine this with a uh a sort of uh what is it called is it zip slip because this is a
zip snip but maybe zip you can combine it with a zip slip attack which i think is like a path traversal
in the zip files right yeah um and then you could get arbitrary file right potentially so there's
definitely there's definitely some risk here i wouldn't i don't know that i would go so far as to i mean
we'll see how far how the adoption goes but i don't know that i would be i would go so far as to just
block the whole tld yeah um but you know hey maybe maybe that's the best move and make sure that
because at the end of the day the big risk here is for technical people making mistakes right it's not
a lot of times that um non-technical people are running wget and stuff like that so it's a it's a
little bit on the on the fringe i would say still take some user interactions some social engineering but
definitely you know maybe not the best move from a security perspective yeah and i was thinking like
maybe one of the the more realistic use cases for like the bug bounty side is this is probably going
to come into play around like regex bypasses url like format or host checks and stuff like that where
maybe they're you know inserting just in a file name or or like at the file name portion of a url
and you could somehow terminate the url and just turn it into a valid domain that you own
or pass a regex check that is making sure it ends in dot zip or something right like where normally
this would be impossible but now you can have a domain and get a redirect or something so
yeah i think there are there are some creative use cases and it's just one of those things to
maybe note down in in your brain in the in your giant brain database that like okay this is a
thing that exists maybe maybe i'll pull on that later yeah for sure i mean in and yeah like i mean we
could even use it for like a like almost like a link hijacking thing too if somewhere in like a
a flow of uh you know like a ci chain or something like that there could be someone accidentally putting
a space and now you know between the zip file and now you can just register that domain in the boom
so yeah or like converting relative url to like a full domain or something like that yeah that would
be really cool sweet all right let's see what's the next one we got oh okay i can talk talk about
this one so the next one that i wanted to talk about was um this post from uh if secure i'm not
even going to try to say his his real name ivan is his first name fratrick ivan fratrick uh if secure
and uh this is actually from may uh 11 so actually yeah this is still in this episode's uh sort of
period but uh it was recently disclosed that he found a bunch of bugs in sip um which i think is a
really cool protocol and i think is one of the easiest protocols um to sort of go after uh as an
http bug hunter um you can if you go after um sip it's very similar to http in a lot of ways um i found
some bugs in this protocol i had a previous live hacking event and uh it was a lot of fun um so
definitely want to encourage people to go there read read through these um cvs and these are actually
really really simple bugs too i mean like he said in the tweet in the sub tweet um one of them is is
literally just like a you could fit it into a tweet it's just like you know sip slash 2.0 a a a a a a
foo and that gets mis-parsed and causes a buffer overflow yeah worth noting you can fit it in a
tweet without a twitter blue subscription yeah oh there you go you can fit anything in a tweet now
but nowadays oh that's sad um but yeah so definitely definitely something to check out and i also i'm
just personally looking forward to the next opportunity i get the next excuse i get to audit some c code
directly um and look at you know these sort of vulnerabilities because that's not something i'm
comfortable doing and something i've done not something i've done in the past um beyond you
know rudimentary stuff so i think taking a protocol that something that i'm familiar with like sip
and going and excuse me reading the file you know trying to find some bones in a different
protocol for a change could be a really refreshing route to take yeah i agree i think that's that's one of the
like little kind of mini goals that i've kind of set where i i think it would be really cool if um
to like fuzz like a project like an open source project and like go from like start to finish of
like having a crash and actually like getting a full exploit on it yeah i agree i think that'd be really
cool yeah cool um yeah so uh next up we've got this awesome tweet thread um from hack luke uh this
was a couple days ago on the 13th and uh basically he just he created a little thread that
that are some basically 10 tips on that he recommends on how to crush your bug bounties
right and so i think this is like really relevant and has some awesome uh sort of cross crossing you
know uh trends and themes that we've talked about on our podcast in the past for sure um but you know
number one start right like i mean this is like i it seems it sounds obvious right but like
it's it's huge like you have to just like take some initiative and just like
it's it seems super overwhelming and like intimidating um a lot of the people that i
talk to are like new hackers one of the biggest things i hear is like decision like fatigue right
they open hacker one they go to the programs and there's a thousand programs what what do you pick
what do you hack on who do you you know focus on well that's the thing i mean people and nothing is
people will jump back and forth from from okay i need to do um port swigger you know web academy
w whatever whatever that thing is port swiggers you know training thing which is amazing and one of
my top recommendations by the way um to bug crowd university to hacker 101 to you know naham sex channel
to insider phd's channel and they just jump around and that's great and you absolutely need to consume
that material but you can't do that forever sometimes you got to get you got to get in the situation
you got to get your hands dirty you got to make a bunch of mistakes and waste a bunch of time
that should be your goal like like i you can't be afraid of that like you got to get in there and
say like all right for every hour i waste right now trying to hack this or you know not finding
anything that's another hour that i'm not going to have to spend before i find my my own
vulnerability and to be honest like that sounds like a bunch of bs but i promise you
that will that will provide you value in the long run yeah um so i really like that and the reason why i
threw this on the doc for this time was um yeah you know we get this question this is the number one
question we get and this podcast is not super oriented towards beginners um we may do a beginner's
episode at some point but the number one dm that we both get is like hey how do i start in bug bounties
how can i do bug bounties and um and so this is a great place to to look at um for any of you that are
are getting ready to start the process um read through these and and take a look at hack luke's
other content because yeah this is a good a good path to get rolling yeah well and and i think what
you talked about is a is a great strategy just generally speaking but also like especially for
bug bounty bug bounty is not one of those things that's guaranteed right and we've talked about this
a lot where you can spend hours days weeks and not find something that you would consider you know even
high enough to submit and i think it's important to set those kind of like check marks or checkpoints
or whatever like set yourself some boundaries in terms of okay write it down if i hack for eight hours
today and i find nothing then i'm gonna do something else or i'm gonna take this action or you know plan
ahead and write it down so that you can sort of frame your your your mind looking forward so that
when you hit that point you're not like all right now what right because you've already made a plan for
it and that'll help you feel like less lost unless like like you haven't accomplished stuff yeah for
sure man i think we and we've got it in the ideas doc but i think we should definitely do a brain hacks
episode of critical thinking just kind of talking about some of the brain hacks that you need to be
able to survive the bug bounty industry because it's really it's really stressful man and it's hard
you know it's a it's a results for you know results for money sort of situation which is always
stressful and it's uh you know it's it's a high fomo situation it's a high um imposter syndrome
situation so there's a lot of um mental toughness that you need to develop which i've had the opportunity
to benefit from you know being around some of the people that have you know gone before me and taught
me some of these things at the live hacking events but not everyone gets that opportunity and so i think
we ought to i think maybe we'll bump that to the to the top of the list for our upcoming episodes
because i think that could be really of some value yeah yeah that's a good one cool um let me just run
through the rest of these these real quick um number two targeting fresh programs like we talked
about it's like you know how do you pick somewhere to hack look for new scope stuff that have people
haven't touched that's going to be more ripe for easy findings and all that kind of stuff where i just
found that bug today yeah exactly focus on your strengths right so this is like if you want to find
something you want that satisfaction don't be like you know oh let me learn the about mobile for the
first time and like yeah you know you might find a vol that way but like if you know how to web hack just
do some web hacking it's going to be easier you're you're going to have less nuance unless you're not
going to have to be going back and googling all this stuff so much it'll be a lot easier yeah and and so
just just i'll jump in and comment on that one while we're here so i i definitely agree with this but
i agree with this more for the beginners of hacking right like and if you're a web dev you should
find web phones if you're a mobile dev you should find mobile phones um you know if and we've talked
about this in the past as well if you can hack a product that you use you know hack a product that
you are actively using as user um and you'll find you'll find that things will go a lot easier for
you all right continue sorry for sure no no no absolutely i appreciate the the input number four
autumn use automation wisely we have a whole episode about this like when to automate and like where to draw
that line and i totally agree with with hack luke before you know if you want to save yourself some
time like you can automate stuff but you have to be aware that it can often lead to you know false
positives fake findings all that kind of stuff so you really need to supplement it in there to save
yourself some time but don't waste your time by then having to check all those results like a double
check it and trust and not trust it and all that kind of stuff or modify the script time and time again
like i was talking about at the beginning of the episode you know it definitely becomes a thing you
know and i've recently also i i used to be a just my own tool sort of guy like i ran besides stuff like
you know mass dns which i'm not going to go write everything in the low level language and stuff like
that i would mostly use my own tools designed the way that i wanted them and that sort of thing but
lately i've really gained an appreciation for uh specifically project discovery tools with httpx and
dnsx and just essentially very um linux um what is linux i can't think of the word in english that i'm
trying to say the the form the flow of how linux does it right uh flow of those tools you know where
you can pipe stuff back you know into other tools and the way that they connect together um and so i
think that's that that's really cool as well you know being able to use other people's tools
effectively and build that into your own flow and not always having to build your own stuff because
that definitely will become a time a time drain yeah cool so number five practicing on vulnerable apps
um i think i i'm a little bit conflicted about this one because we've had some discussions about
this i think off the air about like yeah you know new hackers and stuff again i have lots of
friends and people who are getting into hacking and they're like oh i was spending you know a bunch
of hours like doing damn vulnerable web app or or hack the box i'm like that's awesome but but you
you should like i would encourage you to like now that you've got like your hands around sort of the
basics and you've got some ideas go do some real hacking like go do some bug bounty like absolutely you
know i don't want to say it's a waste of time because it's not like it's a learning experience right
and like i think cts and that type of like structured volm that like you know it exists you just have to
figure out how to exploit it it's great practice however if you're really trying to optimize your time
and like use it efficiently and get like that real world experience jump into bug bounty as soon as you
can so that you can really like start to look at real apps and less of these sort of set up
structured preconditioned scenarios totally agree yeah number six read reports from other hunters i would
put this right on par with reading blog posts and like you know making bookmarks and doing your own
research and all that kind of stuff um it also goes really well with the next one which is engaging
with the community i think like staying in tune with what's going on within both just the general
security community as well as bug bounty community on twitter on blogs on on ccbb podcast
odds yeah the critical digging bug bounty podcast you know what i'm talking about
yeah like any of those types of methods like it's like shouting out our podcast on our podcast yeah
yeah yeah the fact that you're listening to this right now like already tells you you're already
doing it right yeah you're in there you're engaging with the community you're reading
slash listening to reports all that kind of stuff this is like a great way to get that kind of
firsthand knowledge from like you know like otherwise how are you going to find this stuff like
you know it's it's really really hard this is one of the things that i think a lot of bug bounty
hunters struggle with is finding this kind of information out there like openly and freely and
in in a way that's accessible for them to to read and and understand yeah yeah for sure um on so
document everything we've also that's the next one that's number eight we talked about that a little
bit um i don't do it so well but i i've realized after we did that episode talking about that that i
uh have actually do it a little bit more than i thought so you know especially when i'm leaving a
target and i'm you know holding those uh work-life balance boundaries really well when i say okay you
know what ding ding alarm's going off it's 4 45 or whatever i'm gonna spend the next 15 minutes
cleaning up my my you know uh home directory and uh and documenting all my stuff and you know knowing
where i left off brain dumping my attack vectors and that sort of thing and i think also working with
you in the last event made us do that a little bit better too we uh we got our own little um hack md.io
um notes up and we're dumping dumping sort of potential leads in there so i think that was i think that
was really good um but it's definitely not something that i i don't know i wouldn't put that in like the
top now maybe it makes the top 10 you know maybe it makes the top 10 yeah yeah i mean i was gonna say
the same thing is this is something i'm i'm not the greatest at and haven't been the greatest at
historically but starting since like the last event i've i've been getting better at it and i think
finding a good system whether that's hack md or something else to to like help you structure notes
in in a way where it's it's not quite brain dumping but it's more it's a little more organized right
and like some way to structure that brain dump i think i've seen a couple tools i can't remember
what they are but hack md is really like the first one that comes to mind and i think something like
that is a great idea even if it's just local markdown files yeah not hack md but like whatever
you want to do to just take notes so that you have someplace you can search and reference back
is a great idea yeah my brain just automatically writes markdown anyway i can't even use google docs
anymore it just has to be marked down yeah um so be persistent and enjoy the process of the last two
and that's that's something that i kind of wanted to uh talk about recently because i i do get all
like i mentioned before i do get all these messages on like hey how do i do this what should i do how do
i hack i had a conversation with a guy i'll give him a shout out here if i can find his name
uh yeah it's pran shucks o x um and i was talking to this person and they were saying hey you know
should i pivot to a different program you know tell me exactly what to do and this is what i told
him i told him i told him hey go to your target spend four hours using the application and writing
down every single attack factor you can think of in as my minute detail as you can possibly think of
then go back and test every single one of those very thoroughly think about when you think you've
tested it think about it again and make sure you you have tested it properly from every single angle
and he did that and he found some bugs and i was really happy to see that
um and and then he said hey you know i found some bugs but to be honest i feel like i'm
getting through you know everything that i can find you know on this target and i said that's perfect
that's where you want to be now answer me this do you know that api better than any other bug bounty
hunter do you know that api better than the devs that wrote that api no then stay stay there do not
pivot just yet because really the way the way you you get some of these crazy volumes is by is by
becoming a mega expert on these things you should see some of the guys um i won't shout them out
specifically because i'm not sure how how much information about their flow they want to give
out but like some of the top hackers on very singular programs you know you go and see them and they
have literally built full applications around documenting the api and how the you know authorization
structure works on these applications so they literally have built an application to help them document
the application of their target like that's the kind of badass like i'm totally addicted to this like
you know concentration that you need to find crazy bugs and destroy a target so um definitely agree with
with luke's uh topic here on being persistent and uh yeah enjoying the process that's another thing is
just being naturally curious not stressing too much about hey am i finding volumes am i not finding volumes but
trusting the process and enjoying it along the way and you'll have better results that way for sure
yeah yeah that persistence thing that's something we've we've talked about and i couldn't agree more
like deep dive like go deep as deep as you possibly can because that's where you're going to start to make
some of those like key connections like in your brain like oh i wonder if this thing is accessible through
this other endpoint or whatever and and finding those hidden endpoints in the javascript or or in the
mobile app or whatever like you know figuring out different ways to to map that api as good as a developer
can i think that that's like really one of those those key those key things that makes the difference between like
the number one on the program and the number three four five totally agree man um okay cool so definitely
check out uh hack luke's uh twitter thread we'll we'll put it in the description the next one that i
wanted to talk about is a link treat tweeted out by mokuso um mokuso4 on twitter um and he tweeted out a
link to asset note uh an article that they published recently on bypassing iis authorization
i love the title you know you definitely know shoves just went to google it's like how to write
a clickbaity title bypass is is authorization with this one weird trick like i love it um and and he got
three rces so you know for for for what he can't he can't do in clickbaity titles he definitely can do
with the hacking um no but this this this write-up is like a uh is a masterpiece man um i was just talking
to joel about it before the the episode um just stunning and i'm really glad that it popped up
today and i'm actually glad we put it at the end of our uh actually so you actually also had something
else you want to talk about right shadow clone so let's let's go let's go jump to that first and then
we'll come back to this blog by acid note because um i i want to talk to that in the context of the
the source code review stuff that we're going to do after that yeah for sure yeah so we it's basically
you know two two a double whammy both from shubs here um infosec au uh and so shubs tweeted out a
couple weeks ago maybe like two and a half weeks ago at the end of april uh that he had spent a
couple hours uh you know working with this tool called shadow clone um and he said that you know
once you get everything set up and you get your python and matching the runtime python and everything
basically works outside of the box and you can use httpx which is a tool that we've talked about before
yeah yeah 100 really awesome tool to scale your scanning out across you know a ton of different
instances he said he did 150 000 subdomains in three to four minutes um that's pretty awesome and if you
look at this this project it's called shadow clone um and i had never heard of this until uh shubs tweeted
it out but essentially it's inspired and very similar to axiom and fleeks which are two other kind of like
distributed um you know vps type like task running solutions that exist uh but the big difference at
least that's claimed within these docs i haven't tested this myself is that one you can have like
10 times more instances up to a thousand instances it's mostly free uh compared to
essentially pricing per instance and per minute uh with axiom and it's faster and it's basically free
like nice there's no idle cost yeah so i may have said i may have said it's mostly free twice
we're emphasizing that that point very good again mostly free yes so that's what it literally says in
the docs too mostly free mostly free yes and and the mostly is like you know technically there are
limits like in the millions on how many like calls you can make but the way that this works is
it uses um these uh these these dynamic like serverless functions to run your tasks so it'll
take your input file it'll split it line by line and then it'll run like it'll distribute it among a
bunch of different instances and it's uses like free tear instances and all that kind of stuff so it
basically costs nothing again and uh yeah i mean it seems really really awesome kind of similar to um
fireprox which we were talking about uh maybe a week or two ago that is kind of like this but just for
the request side where it does it puts it through an api gateway so i think this is a really awesome
tool it's certainly more flexible than the fireprox stuff that we talked about um and i think it's a
really awesome way to you know distribute your scanning so you're not taking down taking down services
i really i really like that it supports the different it supports google aws and azure too um i think that's
that's pretty rad yeah that's awesome all right cool um let me just actually i'm just gonna get
clone this down right now before i forget because i'm gonna i'm gonna forget if i don't do it um okay
cool so yeah going back to what i was talking about before um like you said double special today for for
shubs killing it always with the content um so yeah the reason why i wanted to butt this right up to our
conversation about um about uh source code review is because it's pretty much a master class in source
code review um and i think this just reinforces the point that that um that hack luke um made in in the in
the post of just making sure you're religiously reading um the posts by respected hackers uh you
know that you that you admire and shubs is is the top of that list for me he really is um and so you
know in this this extends not only not only to people that are trying to learn or get into the space but
also to top hackers we have to stay on top of this stuff and continue reading and it just becomes sort
of a memory you know a muscle reflex now every anytime i see anything like this come out that i've
got to get through it so um the list does get kind of long and overwhelming sometimes but once you
get into it it's really it's really valuable um okay so last week we talked a little bit about um
vs code and and how to use it and that sort of thing and we we addressed some of the stuff that
we wanted to get to with source code uh review but we uh like we talked about how to get access to
source code we talked about you know docker containers uh npm libraries um leaks on github uh
you know trying to get free trials of software um and now you've got the source code you know maybe
you pull it from an lfd maybe you do one of those things um but what do you do with the source code
after you've gotten it so that's what we want to spend some time talking about today um and uh this
article by by shubs um i think outlines a really good flow and let me just kind of break that down
for us real quick let me let me let me get some water before i do that because it's gonna yeah no
and i just wanted to echo like a master class might even be under understating it just because like
i don't think if i were to tell somebody like how to do source code review it would be much better than
what shubs is doing here because yeah shubs is doing like exactly the type types of stuff that
we're talking about in terms of how to analyze like what you're dealing with how to figure out attack
surface how to figure out how stuff works all that kind of stuff and all of the asset note blog posts
are incredibly like detailed in depth really walking you through like how they're thinking about it
how their tools they're using mentality all of it right and so like that type of insight is really
really useful um and yeah i i mean seriously go go read it but i'll let you yeah let's let's like walk
through so all right cool so we'll walk through this but first joel i want you to tell the people
what is a source what is a sink because those two terms are very important to this flow and a i think
they're the two most important concepts in in source code review yeah so a source and a sink right so it's it
might be kind of straightforward if you think about it but a source is where you're starting and a sink
is where you're ending and so in source code what that really means is a source is something like
an input parameter or maybe a request handler would be your source function and then the sink is going
to be the function that returns a response to the http server or maybe a database database call
execute call or a cursor execution or a query something right yeah that's your sink so basically
starting from some place some path sinking in another place right so when we do source code review
um the reason sources and sinks are really important is because they're the two best places to to start
from so you've got two primary paths that you can go right you can start at a sink and say okay i want
to be able to be able to control data getting passed into this function um and so for a great example of
a good sync would be the python exec function or the python sub process um p open uh function or execute
functions in c and and you know just think about any like any sort of template injection you know any any
any time you're dealing with um a place that you would want to inject to cause a file right you know
for example those would all be great examples of of um of sinks so you've identified these places where
you want to get your data the reason why you want to get that your data there is because you can pivot and
gain greater access control right so for example if we were able to go after the sync p open and we can
get uh in python then we may be able to get our our malicious input in there and then we could execute
system level commands which allows to shell the the server um and so that's that's a that's a great
example of a of a sync now a source like like you said joel you know it that's that's where we're
getting our user data coming in right um and this is another popular place to start from so you can either
start with the sync and work backwards to the source or you can start at the source and work
work forward to the sync um joel which one do you if you had to pick i know that we we both do both
but if you had to pick one which one do you think is like the one the way to go with so personally i
like starting with sinks um but like you said like you have to do both because starting with sinks can
be really great but it's also very frustrating if you keep tracing the back and there's no source and
you don't know what your sources would look like so understanding what where the sinks are and like
finding them can also be a challenge because it's like an unknown number of sinks right like there's
infinite possibilities could depend on the application yeah we just we just did a source code review where
the target uh used calls to the command line a lot um and unfortunately they encapsulated all of
that into one function and that function was secure but if we hadn't known about that that sync if we
hadn't um you know tracked down that sync and then sort of traced it back then we wouldn't have been
able to audit all the paths and actually at the end of the day joel we actually did find one vulnerability
that got paid out using that so i feel pretty good about that that's true um but yeah so i really like
that point is that one of the tricky parts about sinks is there's not like and there are some lists out
there it's like all right here are the sinks for php or whatever but they're not all going to be the
same all the time um and so getting to know your sinks in the application could be a really good
exercise in source code review yeah and then like you said like take your sinks understand sort of how
they work how they're structured where they might be living within the code base and then try and figure
out your sources so like where are http functions being handled where like what is where does inbound
data come in and then see if there's any way to connect the two do they ever interact is there any
sort of middle frameworks where they might be talking with each other are there any ways that you could
maybe use some open-ended side of the application behavior to get your way over to that sink and just
like trying to identify any way to connect those two i think it's really hard to go like completely from
one to the other um without like doing a little bit of both yeah for sure man i totally agree and but i
will say i am in the opposite boat if i had to pick one i would start with sources and the reason for
that is because um a lot of times syncs have to do with stuff like um rce or um command injection or
uh file arbitrary file write or configuration file injection which we'll talk about soon um fun fun
vulnerability there um but uh they don't necessarily always include business logic stuff um and so and
those are still relevant to the application even though we are a lot of times in our auditing source code
we're going for the prize we're trying to get rce you know trying to find deserialization or some of
those other bugs i mentioned um but i think tracing the sources allows me to understand the application
a lot better when i'm first getting into it so um i often start with identifying all the places where
i can trigger something in the application to happen um and then i'll sort of trace those down the paths
and try to map out um you know where what um sort of logic flow it has what if statements what functions are being called
and and then use that to understand the application and then once i sort of understand the application
having mapped out a lot of those paths then i can kind of say okay well maybe i've got the sink and then
maybe i can work backwards from there but if i had to pick one of the two i think i would start with
start with the sources yeah yeah and i think like that approach is also like completely reasonable
because understanding your attack surface is highly important right it's just like it is like like
you don't have to go from the sinks if anything you know going from the sources probably makes a little
more sense because you're hunting for things that you know are reachable and you're at least able to
understand like where your data is going from the edge inwards versus trying to find some way out from
deep within right and so yeah yeah i think like it just depends on maybe what you're looking for
or or you know what your time constraints are or if you have a ton of sinks it might not make sense to
go through every single one it might be easier to just start with the sources and yeah there's the
sources starting with the sources definitely takes more time i think if you're trying to find a quick
rce or quick bug then it might be best to work from sinks backwards but then if you start from sources
you can also try to find areas where authorization breaks down and have business logic impact so i think
that's i think that's yeah another another cool route like you said okay so the way that i wanted to
sort of uh so i wanted to break that down for for y'all just kind of have that conversation make sure we
understand the terminology of sources and sinks quick editor's note before we get into the next section
the article that we're talking about was released by asset note which is a company owned by shubs
but the actual author of the article was an asset note employee by the name of dylan pinder
dylan is also tremendously skilled i've heard shubs talk about him in the past so
uh sorry for the misattribution dylan um great work on the write-up and great work on the book
all right cool with that cleared up back to the show and then i also kind of wanted to talk about
um how this correlates to shubs is write-up and how he actually uses one of my main tricks for
it's not really a trick it's just how you find the stuff uh to to find sources and what he does uh
you know if you look in the reconnaissance section of the write-up um he he one of the first things he
does is he looks at i'm trying to find all the files that he can access and then he says unfortunately
we couldn't find much of them and so then he goes and looks in the web.config file which shows the
routing for the application so this is an extremely important piece you have to understand how your
application well actually we can even take a step back right joel we can say uh not even routing at
this point what services are running on the application right what are on the on the target you
know you might be you might be interacting with an iot device you might be interacting with something else
but um what kind of services are running are there internal services running behind a reverse proxy
are there are there services running on on um different ports that you can't even hit from
you know various interfaces that you could use to pivot having an understanding of that flow
i think is extremely important um and that should be the first place to start and then once you've
identified the services you can get into routes and stuff like that yeah for sure i think like this
is one of the best approaches because you're starting from like the very beginning right you're looking
at the configuration file very good place to start yeah from the very beginning sorry i went all like
nursery rhyme mode there go ahead sorry yeah so i i just think like configs are a great place to start
you know because like how does it work how is it configured right and yeah go from there that's a
great source of truth yeah for sure so so what he does here is he he takes a look at the web
config file in the site core config file and he finds the ways that various requests are being routed
um and what kind of paths you can hit in the application and then you know he mentions it's a
little bit further down let's see if i can find it in the in the write-up but um he does an excellent job of
well we'll we'll get to that when we get to it but essentially um bypassing an authentication flow
and actually this proves one of my theories wrong that i was going to tell you guys about this week
but i i i think i'll change my my my thought on this before i um uh you know with with shoves right
up i would normally say uh that you should try to understand the auth scheme and then understand
whether you're trying to find auth or unauth vulnerabilities and then go look at the unauth
scope if you're trying to find unauth vulnerabilities right but really that's the felicious assumption
because the the further you understand the auth and how the auth is working there then you may be able
to find bypasses like he does in the situation so um he actually looked at auth and unauth scope and then
figured out a way to you know sort of get around the auth flow that the application was implementing
um to access some some functionality um so that was that was really impressive um and and so just to
sort of walk through this flow he looks at the site core uh config file and the web config file he
identifies how the application is routing various requests and then he um is taking these dll files
out he's uh decompiling them which with with uh dnspy like like we mentioned um that's not the one
that you recommend right dot yeah i recommended dot peak dnspy is a little bit older and i think it's
actually not in active development anymore however it does allow you to do debugging specifically which i
think is one of the reasons why um the asset team decided to use this because you can set break points
within running apps without the source code and then you can hit those break points and make sure
that like what you think is happening is actually happening and so that's super super useful for for
figuring out if your exploit is working and if it's not why not and and all that yeah i've done that in
the browser but that is actually something i've never done and something that i do want to do
in something that i'm reverse engineering is you know loaded up into uh something where you can set
break points and stuff like that and and there are very specific situations where you can do this you
can do it in java a decompiled java and you can do it in um and obviously in dot net here like what they've
got um but that i think that's really cool so then what he does is he identifies um this site core dot mvc dot
dll um file and he identifies how various things are being routed he identifies um slash api slash site
core slash controller so that this is the controller variable and slash action so now he's got he's
opened up to himself a scope that's really um that's really important and joel this is the kind of thing
like what we did with um well i'll i'll i'll bleep it later with uh was when you know we found the
the endpoint where the endpoint we knew that this is where we needed to get access to functionality
and then we made it our mission to get to that that point where we could access those routes to
open up the scope right so it's not necessarily our hacking isn't necessarily always focused on like
how do i get to the sync but also expanding the scope that you can have access to and i think that's
something you did a really good job of in the past uh event was you you know we had it we found that
that target that we needed to get access to and then you were able to find a way to get access to that
which expanded our scope so much allowed us to text so test so much more um source code and uh and
really opened it up so um that's the same sort of thing he's doing here he's identifying a way to
trigger different functions within the application and then he's being able to use that to you know sort of
weave through the application and hit various endpoints the routing in this application is really
funky um and so um he uses that to eventually get rce through um leaking a file uh a web config file
and that file contains the the keys for um good old an operator that we mentioned earlier um his tell uh
telerik exploit which came back in 2019 which is used all the time excellent exploit um because in
that enabled him to use that exploit because the encryption keys are stored um in the web.config file
so that resulted in rc via deserialization um through uh what what was really an lfd um right which we
talked about last time as well yeah and just an awesome like just like a great way to show chaining
different parts of the application really going deep and understanding these separate moving parts and
how they connect together and then tying it all into one big nice putting a nice little bow on it and
handing the team this beautiful poc that does everything all together right yeah yeah absolutely i i love that
and then the the other thing that i wanted to um point out and let me just go ahead and note down
what time we said the things that we need to bleep out because i'm definitely hope i don't forget to
do that um uh but yeah so the other thing that i wanted to point out was this was behind off right
like i mentioned before and so what he does then is he continues to look for a way to um to bypass off here
and uh the way that he ends up doing that is by looking very closely at um the uh this dot context
user identity is authenticated check right so how is that how is that being generated and um after
deep diving into that um and looking into sort of how that functionality is created he found that and i
love this this is such a great hack dude i just i love it right because you know when you have a user
and it's something like is authenticated it's like okay well i'm gonna have to be a user at some point
not necessarily because what he finds is that um there's some functionality surrounding mailing lists
and uh let me just go ahead and read the line it's a site core could be configured with a rendered or
renderer user to enable a user who is subscribing to a mail list to access information without having to
log in when they view the email so when they when they've clicked on the link from their email freaking
brilliant and then when when viewing these items i'm just going to finish reading this when viewing
items this way the user provides some query parameters such as ec underscore message underscore
id and ec underscore id which tells site cores the details of the email item they are viewing and you
know what that freaking does that configures the user property on the application um to be the user
that the renderer user and bypasses the is authenticated check which allows you to access some of this
functionality and i'm just like what a masterpiece yeah right beautiful the stars have aligned like
it's amazing that's how it always feels you know with these things is like wow look at this you know
alignment phenomenal so really just to review really quickly here what shubs does is he looks through
the routes understands how the application is routing understand expands his scope by getting access to
this api site core and then being able to define the controller in the actions audits the code in the
controller that is in the actions finds a sync that we didn't really talk about too much but was
essentially a a preview functionality that allowed him to pass in a parameter which led to local file
disclosure and use that lfd to disclose the web.config file which contained the encryption keys which he could use for a known cv by an operator
himself to get a deserialized rce and then made that a sort of a semi-unauthenticated bug by
using abusing the is authenticated check which can be sort of spoofed by subscribing to a mail list and then
clicking a link from the mail list which will generate these ec message parameters that can be used to
get your uh is authenticated your current user uh authenticated user to be rendered a renderer user rather than
just no user right i mean just like yeah crazy like just like an amazing like combination of of of
different bugs and different like pieces of knowledge throughout the application and just just
uh just well done to the asset note team incredible amazing route so route expansion or route you know
understanding the routes expanding your scope finding your your sync um those are those are some major
some major pieces of this uh some major takeaways from this this article you know the the flow that he had
there so anyway really cool that that came up that this week when we were wanting to talk about that
um the sources and syncs thing um and we we spent a lot of time already talking about doing an in-depth
talk on a vulnerability um so i think we'll save any any report um summarization for next time if that
works for you joel yeah yeah i think that's all good okay sweet all right we'll call it there
all right sounds good that's the pod peace
yo um i've recorded this outro so many times this one's gonna be the last one i i'm done um
if you enjoyed the episode please head over to youtube uh find our channel at critical
thinking podcast and drop us a subscribe also on your podcast app of choice just just subscribe
please and we don't want you to miss an episode we want to keep hanging out um finally if you could
tell someone about the podcast that would be amazing that would make my day tell your tell your friend
tell your weird neighbor tell your hacker chats tell anyone who'll listen go go to chat gpt and
tell chat gpt about critical thinking bug bounty podcast all right guys see you next week after having
so much fun recording these outros i figured i'd throw a couple bloopers in for y'all at the end
enjoy um and drop a like subscribe whatever there hack hack hack
yo thanks for listening to this episode of critical thinking bug bounty podcast if you enjoyed head over
to youtube and drop a like and subscribe and also subscribe on your youtube nope